the Batman Arkham franchise has grown to
become quite an extensive series with a
timeline that Glides its way through
five Mainline games a handful of
spin-offs a plethora of tie-in comic
books a novel a VR experience and a
movie but how does everything tie
together well for a standalone Batman
timeline it does a pretty good job of
bringing all the iconic elements from
across the Batman mythology together
albeit with the odd curveball
then there's the introduction of The
Suicide Squad into the mix who each make
plenty of appearances throughout the
timeline before eventually starring in
their own game and to confuse matters
somewhat there's also Gotham Knights
which despite featuring many of the same
characters from the Arkham timeline is
not set in the same universe so don't
make that mistake I guess with Suicide
Squad killed the Justice League set to
expand the Canon of the Arkham verse
what better time to recap the
franchise's entire story so from Arkham
Origins all the way through to the
suicide squad's quest to kill the
Justice League this is the complete
Batman Arkham timeline explained
foreign
[Music]
kicks off with Batman Arkham Origins
which like the 2022 movie The Batman
takes place during Bruce Wayne's second
year as The Dark Knight rather
unglamorously though first up on our
chronology is an Arkham origins DLC
challenge pack known as initiation which
sees a pre-batman Bruce Wayne traveled
the world on a rather unorthodox Gap
year our Bruce ends up in North Korea of
all places where he trains with the
legendary martial arts master kirigi at
his secret Castle Dojo following his
training in Korea Bruce heads back to
his hometown of Gotham City and
establishes his alter ego of the Batman
as a means to clean up the corruption
Rife in the city from the streets all
the way up to the top and it's this
fresh young Batman that we catch up with
during his second year of bat service in
Arkham Origins deck the halls with bows
of whatever as Arkham Origins kicks off
on Christmas Eve with Batman pitted
against eight assassins on a decidedly
unsilent night those eight assassins
including among others Killer Croc
Deathstroke Deadshot and Bane are all
after bats due to a whopping 50 million
dollar Bounty placed on his head by a
ruthless mob boss known as black mask
this deadly night before Christmas sees
our rather inexperienced Kate Crusader
come head to head with each of these
assassins as he attempts to cut to the
core of the bounty black mask to
absolutely no one's surprise black mask
is actually the Joker in Disguise and
Batman eventually catches up with and
subsequently thwarts the Crown Prince of
Crime before leaving him in the welcome
Hospitality of the gcpd incarcerated at
Blackgate Prison The Joker Is left under
the care of one Dr harleen quinzel and
so begins a beautiful and deranged
relationship that will catch up with
plenty on this timeline naturally The
Joker doesn't stay in custody for too
long as he soon incites a riot to gain
control of the prison facility and
establish a devious challenge to
Batman's no kill rule Batman realizing
he's way out of his depth enlists the
help of Captain Jim Gordon and the gcpd
to retake the prison and defeat the
Joker which they eventually do despite
Joker's incessant Golding for the bats
to kill him the game ends with Jim
Gordon letting Batman Go believing it's
the best thing to do for the greater
good of Gotham except there's a cheeky
little post-credit sting that sees
Amanda Waller visit an imprisoned
Deathstroke to sign him up for a new
team she's putting together known as The
Suicide Squad more on them later
[Music]
just a short three months later we catch
up with the Kate Crusader wrangling with
the joker Black Mask the real one this
time and the Penguin yet again with all
three jailed at the titular Blackgate
Prison Batman is called upon by Jim
Gordon to infiltrate the penitentiary
and shut each of the super villains down
complicating matters somewhat is one
Selena Kyle AKA Catwoman who appears to
Aid our bats but is secretly on her own
mission for Amanda Waller a mission to
secure Bane long story short Batman
takes down the Joker the Penguin and
black mask and Catwoman is arrested
rescued by Rick flag alongside Bane
who's also in League with Walla and in
another post-credits scene we learned
that while flag and his team had to
return Bane to the custody of the gcpd
they did secure Deadshot and a lad
called Bronze Tiger amidst the Blackgate
riots that Suicide Squad just got a
couple of new recruits
you know
okay so you might have noticed that
there's a huge time Jump between
Blackgate and Batgirl and while a fair
few things happen in this period none of
it really happens in the game so it's
nothing really that I can show you so
let me run through the key points real
quick so Arkham Asylum is reinstated
Dick Grayson Witnesses his parents dying
is taken in by Bruce Wayne which sets
him on the path to becoming Robin a path
that he walks away from two years later
when he moves to the nearby city of
bloodhaven where he takes up the mantle
Nightwing meanwhile Jason Todd becomes
the second incarnation of Rodney before
he takes on the Joker single handling
appears to be killed a plot point that
will have huge ramifications later on
and then a lad called Tim Drake becomes
the third flavor Robin in his many years
and it's this version of Roman that we
see teaming up with Barbara Gordon's
background on the Arkham Knight DLC a
matter of family
and breathe
anyway there's not much story in a
matter of family it's basically Batgirl
and Robin rescuing Batgirl's dad Jim
Gordon from The Joker aboard the
offshore Seagate amusement park they
rescued Jimmy boy arrest Harley but
Joker escapes to terrorize another day I
know I couldn't believe it either
[Music]
speaking of Harley
the timeline is
Suicide Squad movie Batman assault and
Arkham well bats does appear this tie-in
movie sees Amanda Waller's Suicide Squad
made up of Deadshot Harley Quinn Captain
Boomerang king shark black spider and
Killer Frost being tasked with breaking
into Arkham Asylum to assassinate The
Riddler so how exactly does Batman come
into a film sporting his own name well
he's on the hunt for a supposed dirty
bomb that joker has hidden somewhere in
the city how he's done that when he's
back in an Arkham as anyone's guess and
this leads him to cross paths with the
suicide squad as they infiltrate the
Asylum the squad and bats eventually go
head to head where black spider
supposedly manages to take out the Kate
Crusader hmm the squad then catch up to
the Riddler who manages to persuade them
not to kill him in exchange for the
knowledge of how to remove the Nano
bombs Walla has placed in each of their
heads the squad agree and Riddler
manages to remove the bombs but in the
process rather messily kills king shark
and in a Twist that I reckon a fair few
people saw coming reveals Batman's
disguise as black spider as the squad
attempt to escape Arkham Island all hell
breaks loose in the ensuing chaos Harley
rejoins with the joker who Reveals His
dirty bomb is actually in Harley's
Mallet killer frost apparently dies at
the hands of Bane and Deadshot Escapes
in a helicopter leaving Boomerang to the
Arkham authorities all of which leaves
the loose end of Batman hunting down the
dirty bomb which culminates in a
climactic fight between Joker and
Deadshot resulting in Joker getting
dropped off the side of a skyscraper in
a chopper that blows up
[Music]
miraculously he survives otherwise we
wouldn't have the story of the Arkham
Trilogy speaking of which
[Music]
yeah here we finally are the very first
game in the iconic Trilogy Batman Arkham
Asylum and boy does this one sure put
the bat amongst the pigeons Arkham
Asylum kicks off with bats and Jokers
sharing the front seat of the Batmobile
with the latter effectively giving
himself up to the former in slightly
mysterious circumstances inevitably
Joker Breaks Loose while Batman is
escorting him into Arkham Joker's loose
alert the warden and sets in motion his
plan to seize power across the Asylum
turns out Joker has got wind of the
Titan project a supposedly super secret
research program that the renowned Dr
Penelope young has been working on
basically inject yourself with Titan and
you become a pro wrestler while
navigating Arkham Island the world's
greatest detective eventually traces the
source of Titan back to a patient X who
turns out to be poor old Bane Dr Young
has been draining him with the Venom
that turned him into the giant Brick
House of a man and using it as a
catalyst for her experiments with the
Titan project long story short Joker
makes a play for the Titan Serum with a
view producing an army of Titan fueled
Banner likes naturally and caught up in
the mix is a veritable who's who of
Batman's Rogue Gallery with Scarecrow
zaz Harley Quinn Killer Croc and poison
ivy all making for absolutely Stellar
boss fight set pieces as Arkham Asylum
races towards its conclusion Joker
cordly invites Batman to a party in his
honor where he injects both himself and
bat with a dose of the Titan serum while
Joker morphs into a WWE knockoff Batman
resists the serum somehow and injects
himself with an antidote that he
concocted from sewer spores as you do
then the two Face-Off Mano e batmano on
the rooftops of the Asylum with arcade
Crusader eventually coming out on top by
punching Joker Square in the face with a
fist covered and explosive gel which is
a move that should have been useful at
any other point in the game with the job
pretty much done and dusted bats hands
over to a somewhat beleaguered Jim
Gordon and the gcpd round up all the
remaining inmates and with one final
flourish the game ends with a cheeky
little post-credit sting which shows a
randomized villain one of either Bane
killer croc or scarecrow grabbing it a
canister of Titan floating in the Gotham
River
so before we jump into Arkham City a lot
actually happens in the 18 odd month gap
between Arkham Asylum and its Sequel and
large chunks of it take place across the
tie-in comic series Batman Arkham City
and Batman Arkham unhinged now it's well
beyond my capabilities to try and Regale
well over 50 issues worth of plot lines
in a short succinct way so let me break
down some of the saline points that
happen that will help set the scene for
The grandstanding Narrative of Arkham
City firstly Quincy sharp the warden of
Arkham shuts down the asylum in the wake
of Joker's night of chaos and
successfully runs for mayor of Gotham
because nothing says success like
failing to look after an Island full of
deranged supervillains with the Asylum
officially shut down the city looks to
find a new location to house its super
criminals and so Arkham City is born
under the watchful eye of one Professor
Hugo Strange making up a large chunk of
Gotham real estate Arkham City becomes a
walled off open plan jail built to house
inmates from both Arkham Asylum and
Blackgate Prison and yes you're right
that is a shockingly bad idea last but
definitely not least is the bombshell
that the Joker is dying yep the iconic
bat villain is on his way out it turns
out the effect of injecting Titan into
his lanky little body were not good of
course a load more happens but those are
all the essential points to this
timeline so if you want to find out more
go and read the comics eh
right with all that housekeeping out the
way let's dig into Batman Arkham City's
meaty narrative the game kicks off with
everyone's favorite billionaire playboy
getting kidnapped by the penguin voiced
by famously authentic Cockney actor Nola
North our mate Bruce manages to escape
the deformed mobster and makes his way
to the rooftops to Don cape and count
and start kicking some ass and first up
on the ass kicking list is one Harvey
Dent AKA Two-Face who is quarter cat
heads or tails kitty cat and owning two
cats in real life
I know that's a difficult task and has
her suspended over some nondescript
toxic waste which always seems to be
lying around in Batman stories that
saves Catwoman but his attention is
immediately diverted to a bullet trying
to Lodge itself somewhere in his Cranium
using his world's greatest detective
skills Batman tracks the source of the
bullet to a nearby Church Tower where lo
and behold it's Joker behind the trigger
bats tracks his Nemesis to the sionist
power plant where he falls for the old
fake Joker Switcheroo and promptly gets
infected with Joker's disease-ridden
blood for his faux pas and so Begins the
main Narrative of Batman Arkham City
Batman's one-man crusade to find a cure
for the Titan infused virus burning
through his body I guess I should also
mention Professor Hugo Strange sometime
around now too seeing as he is The
Game's main antagonist well as bats Zips
Glides and punches his way around Arkham
City stranger's presence and booming
voice lingers over proceedings
threatening something known as protocol
10. Protocol 10 is ready to begin as the
the hours count down to whatever
Protocol 10 is Batman bounces between
iconic villains as he chases down Mr
Freeze for help in finding a cure this
desperate Mission takes in the penguin
again now secure within the Gotham
Museum and crucially Rochelle ghoul
whose immortality presents the key to
cracking the Cure long story short bat
secures The Cure before losing it
immediately to Joker and confronts Hugo
Strange while Protocol 10 is triggered
turns out Arkham City was all just a
ruse for strange to kill off every
criminal in Gotham thus ridding the city
of crime altogether admittedly by
committing the ultimate crime in the
process but I'm sure he doesn't really
care about that anyway Batman stops him
only for a Twist in the form of a knife
in Strange's back courtesy of racial
ghoul who it turns out has been
spearheading this whole circus from the
very beginning before he dies strange
triggers protocol 11 which is much
simpler than its predecessor and
basically just blows up his penthouse
suite and Batman and rage escape the
resorting explosion and free fall from
the tower which ends well for precisely
one of them and not so well for the
other
Arkham City reaches its conclusion with
yet another Batman vs Joker climax only
this time clay faces and writers of the
party after dealing with the
transmorphing villain bats next The Cure
and watches on as Joker succumbs to his
illness ice cold bats and with that the
game ends with Batman carrying the
Joker's corpse right out the front gate
of Arkham City
[Music]
foreign before I dive into the trilogy
closer let's take a quick look at what
happens in the 10 or so month gap
between Arkham City and night and the
short answer is not a lot obviously I'm
simplifying things as stuff does happen
presumably Batman works out and stuff
but like the gap between Arkham Asylum
and City most of it doesn't really
contribute to the greater narrative one
of the key plot points in the wake of
Arkham City is the closure and
subsequent Redevelopment of that titular
jail and with Joker very much dead
Gotham City falls into a period of
relative calm I say relative as there
are still a handful of iconic
supervillains at large among them are
the Riddler who gets his own tie-in book
the Riddler's Gambit Harley Quinn who's
the focus of not one but two separate
story DLC Packs the second of which
Caesar breaking poison ivy out of jail
and neighboring bloodhaven and most
importantly the Arkham Knight whose
entrance on the Gotham scene is
comprehensively chronicled in the Arkham
Knight prequel comic book series but
that's not the end of it right before
Arkham Knight kicks off on Halloween a
Batman 13th year there's Batman Arkham
VR which I almost hesitate to place on
this timeline because well none of it
really actually happens but what the
hell you see Arkham VR plays The age-old
Narrative trick that it was all a dream
which is a massive copper in terms of
Storytelling but hey I'm not writing
these games
to keep things simple Arkham vrc's
Batman investigate The Disappearance of
both dick Grayson's Nightwing and Tim
Drake's Robin both of which end up dead
at the hands of Batman himself in a
psychological episode that Freud himself
would have loved to analyze it's
absolutely Bonkers and as I said none of
it's real although it might explain why
Batman's so hesitant for Nightwing and
Robin to help in Arkham Knight speaking
of which
[Music]
here we finally are the grand finale of
the Arkham Trilogy and Rocksteady really
threw the proverbial kitchen sink into
this sprawling narrative in an
escalation of the previous two games
Gotham itself is now under attack at the
hands of the Scarecrow who handily gives
everyone a heads up that he's about to
do some evil [ __ ] this leads to a mass
Exodus of the city leaving just the
rotten eggs behind and surely saving
Rock City from having to render a fully
open world Gotham with actual citizens
knocking about but maybe that's just me
being cynical and so Gotham is left to
the criminals that define it
all the favorites are here penguin is
smuggling weapons two faces Robin Banks
hell even Man-Bat is flying around the
rooftops but taking top billing is the
titular Arkham Knight a masked vigilante
in Batman's image that has some serious
beef with the Dark Knight arm to the
teeth and backed up by a private militia
he's a formidable foe hence Batman
having to evening the odds
turns out the Arkham Knight is in League
with Scarecrow to set in motion a
bioterrorism attack that will hit the
entire Eastern Seaboard caught up
amongst it all is beleagued cop Jim
Gordon and his daughter Barbara who
unbeknownst to him is actually working
for Batman as Oracle The Dark Knight
eventually tracks down scarecrow's base
of operations for his attack known as
the cloudburst and while he's limiting
the blast radius he's infected by
scarecrow's fear toxin which mixed with
the mutated blood running about an
assistant from Arkham City leads him to
start seeing hallucinations of his good
old pal Joker which in my opinion is an
inspired way to get a deceased Joker
into your Flagship Batman game Bravo
Rocksteady I digress with Batman seeing
the Joker everywhere he hits the Mean
Streets of Gotham to put a stop to the
Arkham Knight in scarecrow which leads
to some pretty dark places for the
series Chief among them a sequence where
Batman is unable to save a kidnap
Barbara from seemingly shooting herself
in the head on top of that arcade
Crusader is unable to stop the
cloudburst from going off which bathes
Gotham in an eerie or orange smog for a
sizable chunk of the game admittedly
with the help of Ivy who also kicks the
bucket in this game Batman is able to
reverse the cloudburst but most of the
game is still pretty Doom and Gloom for
our dear bats then there's the ongoing
mystery of who the Arkham Knight is and
the answer is drum roll
there's a there's a there's a desk over
there just so you know Jason Todd yeah
the second incarnation of Robin who
Batman thought had died at the hands of
the Joker Well turns out he didn't and
he's seriously pissed hence the Vendetta
Against The Dark Knight after a
prolonged fight Batman eventually gets
through to Jason and appeals to his
better nature from there Batman and
Gordon Tracked Down the whereabouts of
scarecrow and find out that Barbara
isn't dead it was all a fear toxin-based
hallucination Batman hands himself into
the Scarecrow in return for Barbara and
Jim's safety and he's taken back to
where it all started Arkham Asylum there
scarecrow broadcast the big reveal of
who the Batman is to the world and
injects Bruce with more than enough fear
toxin to kill the poor bloke what
happens instead is Bruce goes deep
within himself literally fighting the
manifestation of Joker in his mind until
he has full control again it's really
trippy controlling his fear and With a
Little Help From A redeemed Jason Batman
is able to overcome scarecrow and the
pair take him down and lock him up in
gcpd with Scarecrow behind bars and The
Dark Knight identity revealed Batman
sets about cleaning up the remaining
threats in Gotham before initiating the
Nightfall protocol which sees Bruce fake
his own death in a massive explosion at
Wayne Manor allegedly and the trilogy
finally comes full circle in an
ambiguous final scene which mirrors
Bruce parents death where a pair of
muggers are confronted by a shadowy
figure on a rooftop is it someone else
taking up the mantle of Batman a
fear-induced hallucination or is it
Bruce still alive and now a more extreme
version of Batman utilizing scarecrow's
fear toxin who knows one thing's for
sure a lot happens in Batman Arkham
Knight
[Music]
all of which leads us to the final game
in the series Well for now at least
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
after all those teases back in Batman
Arkham Origins and Origins Blackgate and
well the film as well the suicide squad
have been a long time coming while very
little is actually no known about the
story of the game we do know that it
takes place right at the end of the r
Converse timeline and sees Arkham Asylum
inmates Harley Quinn Captain Boomerang
Deadshot and king shark recruited by
Amanda Waller for an assassination
mission in Metropolis their targets well
the title kind of already tells you that
I guess you see classic Superman villain
Brainiac has made his way to Earth and
has Brainwashed the Justice League
notably Superman the Flash and Green
Lantern into going rogue and that's
pretty much all we know at this stage
but there's plenty of potential for the
story to evolve in a now batman-less
world so watch this space I guess and
that Pals is the Batman Arkham timeline
fully explained do let me know in the
comment section down below what other
gaming timelines you might want to see
and while you're there make sure to
subscribe as we've got plenty on the
channel already stuff like Metroid Halo
Uncharted and Resident Evil thanks a lot
for watching guys I'll see you next time